[Music]
foreign
like townhouse you walk in and it's got
stairs that go up but they sort of go
back deep not terribly wide but a little
bit and there's always a half bath right
when you walk in the front door right
there on your right just a toilet and a
sink okay
he's got these [__] problems he's going
upstairs to the main bathroom he's going
to the second one they're all being used
it's a you know a small townhouse with
like 100 people in it and he's telling
his wife he's like I might have to [__]
in that that half bath and the living
room is packed full of people eating and
everything she's like don't do it he's
like I'm gonna have to [__] I'm gonna
have to go in there and do it and he
just said sorry
anyway
he said he was in there for 25 minutes
it came out he the hope he said the food
everything he ruined everything the
party [__] they all left
and she had to go back and work well he
didn't have to see him she had to see
him they were like man your husband [__]
this house up and ruined the [__]
that's a horrible situation
listen man I used to do a lot of coke so
I go to people's houses I do two bumps
of coat and the first thing you gotta do
is take this [__] and I tell him you got
another bathroom like oh no use that one
like oh Jesus
Hey listen the worst shits you'll take
are the ones in somebody's house the
sticky ones you get two rolls of toilet
paper they don't have no more rolling
paper you gotta [__] yell out for
them for [__] toilet paper the worst
shits I have to take are when I'm out
you know at that coffee shop we go to
Marie oh really and you gotta run to the
bathroom then there's somebody in there
[__] already man get furious yeah well
sometimes I just drink coffee and gotta
pee and I run to the bathroom and
somebody took a [__] in that bathroom my
blood pressure goes 200 over I get
furious people [__] on the outside
because I try my hardest not to [__] oh
yeah I really do I really [__] do I
hate and I always have to [__] when I'm
leaving the house it seems like when I'm
just about to leave the house no more
that's why I'm calm I get up at six I
give myself a few hours
fake it out a little bit this people
will leave the house and expect to go to
somebody else's place or residence or
business and [__] up that was your
friend I understand he was very sick I
don't want people coming over to my
house no hell no not like that you know
when people come over they look like
Ariel come to your house and go can I
use your bathroom that means [__]
you're done
you're done you're done I haven't had a
house with a guy for a while my dad was
just here for a weekend it was this is a
family story that he went we went to hit
my aunt's house and sisters and he
pooped and then my my cousin went in and
puked
how many how many [__]
places that I go to them when I
when I was when you do cocaine it
loosens everything up you start dropping
everything everything Papa legs chicken
wings bones oh my God it's [__]
horrible it's a matchbox that's the one
thing about cocaine you do it and it
cleans you out and then you're running
on an empty stomach the rest of the
night your stomach is growling but you
don't want to eat because you're [__]
doing balance tremendous
um I'll never forget my grandmother used
to tell me this story all the time my
grandmother was hip and uh she and and
one of our cousins he was older but they
shared a birthday December 8th I believe
and uh they would always get together
for coffee and hang out on their
birthday and they went to this place it
was called white coffee pot Junior back
in Baltimore and they were sitting down
having coffee my grandma said oh my God
I need to use the bathroom
so she goes into the ladies room she's
telling us this and she sits she squats
over the toilet and she's got terrible
diarrhea and she said I cleaned myself
and when I was done I turned around to
put the toilet paper in and nothing was
in the toilet and she said I looked up
on the wall and it was everywhere it
sprayed all up on the wall and she's
like oh my God so she runs out and
washes her hands and as she's getting
ready to come out here comes a female
attendant to clean it my grandmother
just looked at her and goes I don't look
with some sick son of a [__] in there
dude that's disgusting hard ass out of
there grab my cousin and said we're
getting nothing perfect yeah it was the
timing of day she just thought quick
like that's [__] disgusting I can't
even be in here I almost [__] myself the
other day I was at the urinal my mom
when my mom my dad and Paula met and I
was taking a piss and I thought I had to
fart and I it like almost came out like
I was able to stop it at the last minute
but it's a horrible situation when you
[__] yourself I do it once a year just
do it you don't know only once a year
but yeah food you don't know you go
there for the first time and you people
in L.A oh it's great food and you go in
there and they give me that [__]
canned shrimp like pan shrimp goes
through me like water yeah last week a
bunch of my friends said that the Golden
Chopsticks is good I'm Laurel Canyon
I've always driven by it so the other
night I go you know what honey you want
Chinese I want Chinese let's go to the
Golden Chopsticks Mercy didn't want to
go nowhere so I gotta go get it we
ordered it on the phone
the shrimp was horrible the wings were
delicious until you bit into them and
then you can see they were glued
together like the 7-Eleven Wings they're
purple they got like a low grade of
wings like the chicken's got cancer or
something they got weak Wings their
wings break
the wings with the listen the best wings
in L.A my wife was saying Best Wings you
could ever have in L.A want all right
rice and La Cienega next to Vito's Pizza
down there oh I know these will be a
place named rice next door now it's
something else they serve sushi but 15
years ago when I was 4 18. I didn't
think I got to be 4 18. I would go to
rice and get three order of wings
six to one order garlic Wings just no
sauce no blue cheese no celery just
[__] Wing meat with garlic juice on
it Chinese style fresh delicious 6.95 a
piece really 8.95 I didn't give a [__]
me and my wife are gonna get the lunch
special and pre-order with [__] Wings
the tables and my wife said to me she
goes we never had those wings again just
delicious and this place the wings were
like I said they were I didn't get sick
the next day I'm not gonna lie to you
the pork fried rice was I didn't eat a
lot of it the shrimp and garlic sauce
was just horrific and it was the shrimp
if they were to use the size big it
would have been once you give me those
little shrimp you're insulting me yeah
thank you you want to use those for
shrimp fried rice I'm not mad at you but
for shrimp and garlic sauce you got to
go a little bigger and we got something
else I ate some white rice and that was
it I love shrimp but I don't get very
many places like it's if I don't I'll
have to go to like a Thai place for a
while before I try like their shrimp pad
thai I'm a seafood snob man people
shrimp cook in like two minutes people
overcook them they're always rubbery and
[__] and then you start freezing them
they don't know how to freeze them yeah
[__] all that [__] up I told my wife to
stop buying the shrimp from Costco yeah
same thing the big bag we went and then
you would go out and eat shrimp you're
like Jesus that tastes like real [__]
shrimp to give me that old flat I
totally that's that old [__] some Jew
listen when they dropped that Exxon oil
some [__] Jew was like go down there
and buy everything up sharks everything
that's floating
We'll Wash this [__] off and we'll
freeze it oh my God
and that's what they did some [__]
sick [__] like dude
I'm kidding they don't show you that
[__] they gotta save them fish if they
weren't sold here they were sold
somewhere else they were sold somewhere
else they scooped those little Exxon oil
fish before the oil goes into the BP one
I think you're saying you will BP Exxon
those [__] off and you're
freeze them you put some salt and pepper
on them to freeze them like that and you
sell them to [__] whoever they don't
know what the [__] yeah and that's why I
think that Costco shrimp is it's
definitely like related to that shrimp
like that second cousins to that oil
[__] [__]
all right to that situation you know I
mean much like what he's saying with you
like you want to hear what you're going
to say next people really enjoy uh you
know the whatever it is behind it uh the
the sarcasm the smart ass-ness the the
the the funny uh the clever you know
because the other thing too is as
comedians we say what people are
thinking but we I think it's our job to
say that same thing in a way they've
never thought of saying that does that
make sense yes yeah that makes a lot of
sense so it's 100 relatable but maybe
you pick the right word here or you know
chose it to say it this way instead uh
and so it still hits home but it's like
wow because I you know I think it's our
job to to write beyond that I think if
someone pays you to see that if I'm
going to relate to you I should be able
to say it to you in a way maybe you
hadn't thought about saying it but you
get my point exactly
that makes sense
[Laughter]
absolutely you're freaking me out
you look good too Joey Diaz so do you
everybody's looking good Lisa yeah I got
some sun to him and [__] this weekend up
there in the southern Resort whatever
the [__] you were I had a good time in
Minneapolis that's a great little
[__] room man I hear yeah the super
nice people I guess some some guy gave
me maple syrup and rice and then he
wrote me a note but he didn't write me
his [__] name I can't even give him a
[__] shout out he gave you syrup and
rice oh is it was it cooked rice or was
it just a bag in a bag to cook it then
some other guy gave me two hits of acid
people ask me if I want to do math
that's a crazy [__] you guys are
gonna send me to the roots I lost the
ass in the crazy house in my wallet
somewhere I don't know what I did with
it oh my God I'll bumped into that
someday when you're in an airport stuck
you stick you have one of your
compartments and there it is a hit of
acid you got a nine hour stop and you
got some e-cigs you got a vapor pen [__]
it you go For Broke Jack I told you I
look here it is I I smoke weed obviously
but drugs have always they've always
scared me for me but in the right
situation what's the worst drug you've
ever done
I mean outside of weed the only two
drugs I've ever done are shrooms one
time and I did uh ecstasy like twice
what'd you think the first time it
didn't work the second time a girlfriend
I was dating from Argentina gave me that
we [__] we went and rented a cab and up
in Big Bear that was the one of the
greatest nights of my life I mean it was
time for oh hours six five hours maybe
and I mean
I I understood finally because everyone
kept describing to me what it did and
how it felt and finally when I felt that
permanent smile get plastered on my face
I was like oh this is what it is and it
was just that was a lot of fun but
shrooms to me I enjoyed that [__] for
like 45 minutes and then I was just like
all right I want this enough get it out
of me get it out of me you know I always
if I ever I don't know most of the time
I don't get high I just you know
smoke and I relax and then you just
dissipate and Float out of it but with
shrooms that [__] just hung around and I
wanted it to be over I was like enough
of this last Sunday we did an acid on
the show and it was uh
pretty intense it got pretty intensive
moments it was and it was fun
and I had to leave because if not we
would have stayed here until six in the
morning like that's how you feed an acid
trip is with people talking in
conversation and smoking weed
I don't know if I could have gone out
publicly like I used to you could go out
publicly on acid when I was 16. where
did you go
I didn't have a house I didn't I I lived
with some people but I couldn't stay in
and watch TV with them and do a head of
acid so you met for your friends
you think I had an ass at 7 30. that met
by 11 you burn you are burning how old
are you 16 17 and you're behind the high
school see I would have come with you
but I would have been scared to death
we'd get in those days you bought 25 got
you like dirty joints so you rolled them
up you rolled up 30 joints before you
went out so everybody knew where they
stood like we're not going home do we
smoke dirty [__] joints like that's
crazy and sometimes we'd smoke 25 and
we'd stick a joint off
for the morning you know like that we
were tight but that was it but we went
out till four or five in the morning
when you trip your [__] balls I don't
think I'd like that walking around or we
do what we did the other night and go to
the midnight movie
that's a blast it's not you don't freak
out sitting in a movie theater No in
fact you can you even concentrate on the
movie Yes the movie sucks you in okay
the colors are brighter at least that's
right yeah at one point the movie would
just sucked in at first you'll be like I
wouldn't take Lee to see like The Rocky
Horror Picture Show oh that was terrible
because I'd kick them I couldn't I'd
stab them while we were sitting there
and go crazy I feel like you'd kill
people at The Rocky Horror yeah like I
went once and they got so excited
they were like jumping up in their seats
a girl broke up with me over not going
to the Rockies
[Music]
we weren't even boyfriend girlfriend
well were you I was 19 she was 27.
she was my neighbor she was an Italian
girl from Milwaukee and she had a sister
Tia Mia
something and she used to cut my hair
man I was a 19 year old kid I just moved
from Jersey to Basalt Colorado Highland
Hills I'm living in Highland Hills in
the house with four [__] bedrooms and
three guys that are [__] each bench
pressing 480. you know one of them went
back to live uh his mom had a heart
attack so he left
and the one guy that was a garbage man
he was a garbage man in Aspen and he'd
come home every night with skis and [__]
like that it was a pretty bizarre time I
was a young kid I was fresh out of New
York everything I looked at had a price
tag you know I was a shark man I was a
[__] shark but these girls lived next
door to me and they were very nice they
come over and they'd make dip and and
they were like Green Bay Packer fans and
we'd watch football and blah blah blah
and the girl said you know I cut hair
the older ones like I cut that so I went
over there one day and she's cutting my
handbook okay
and then you know it just went we were
just friends and and then sometimes I
would go that way she worked at a wine
shop called The Grog Shop I still
remember and I would meet her and she
would give me a ride what's called down
Valley
like if you work in Aspen you have to go
down Valley you have to go past no mass
pass old Snowmass into Basalt and Woody
Creek and all that [__]
so you know we would just flirt
or we just flirt and one night I asked a
black blatantly be
blatantly I said she goes which ice oh
she was cutting my hair and I put my
hand under her skirt
and she goes what's your problem and I
go I like you I got a crush on you she
goes just say so just don't put your
hand under my skirt that's not gentleman
she goes what do you want to do you want
to take me on a date you just want to
[__] just tell me your intentions it was
that blatant
like it was that blatant and I go I
really don't know I just I don't know I
thought I'd take it to a movie or
something and she goes I'll date you but
you got to move out of the next door
she goes I can't date a neighbor it'll
never happen
and I was moving anyway we were moving
at the end of the month so I waited till
July 1st
and I hitchhiked down this is the Savage
I am I [__] hitchhiked down there at
10 o'clock at night
and I just knocked on a screen door and
she's like what are you doing and I go I
moved up I'm ready for a date what do
you want to do and she goes come on in
I think we did a little blow her sister
was there the sister was really nice we
talked for a little while
and then she took me upstairs and I
think we stayed up all night and did
dirty stuff and and she drove me home
the next day and it was like she was all
you know she was older but I remember
the first time my roommate and Snowmass
caught me with it because she would go
to work five to twelve or five to ten so
she would come up in the afternoons and
my buddy would be you know working but
he knew her from the building we all
lived together next door and I just
never told him that I was with it
Nobody's Business
oh she came up one afternoon with brie
cheese that's the first time I ever brie
cheese and an apple dog I'm an american
cheese type of guy at that time I'd only
tasted American and swiss cheese and
that was all and she showed parmesan oh
she showed up with brie [__] cheese
and an apple and she smitted on the
apple and I'm like are you [__] crazy
I'm from Jersey right yeah right at that
time I was hustling Columbia House yeah
I remember the record company named
Colombia yeah so I was hustling him so I
was like uh 20 cassettes for a penny or
something like that eight cassettes they
had that with CDs when I was growing up
then the next three words right 21.99
and you had to buy four albums in a year
to cancel your subscription [__] you I
would put that Penny on a postcard
because remember you got to put a penny
you had a [__] Scotch tape a penny on
it and your little stamps for the album
if you wanted for the albums and send it
so I would keep sending it to the same
address only in the different names so
my godmother wouldn't know what the [__]
was going every time I go to my Gardener
she can you keep getting these bills up
here who's Carlos Torres
don't worry about it and then I started
doing it
I started doing anybody's house I went
that would take their address down and I
would talk to my mother my mother would
go you got a box over at Guillermo's
house
and I go really that's it and I go over
the Guillermo's housing for a year he
got bills for me and he would come to
the bar why am I getting bills in my
house from Columbia House I scan for
Columbia House like every album they had
Christmas album black albums Spanish we
had a teacher that told us if you're he
told us in high school and we were we
were sophomores he gained it straight up
he's like I'll be honest with you if
you're under 18 you don't have to pay
for [__] and he told all of us he
encouraged us go get all those CDs you
want and then when they send you a bill
he said take out a crayon and write I'm
16 and send that [__] back you'll never
hear from them ever again
so we would do the same thing but we
wouldn't do it that much we would send
it to the a buddy over here or down the
street oh I ordered everything yeah um
I wanted a little trophy when I first
came from Cuba I couldn't wait to get a
trophy just a trophies
sometimes you just want a trophy
sometimes you want to kick it I just
wanted a joke what kind of trophy do you
want so I just want to trouble for
anything so Joe weeda had this thing
yeah there's a guy at the beach a chick
with a skinny guy at the beach and the
muscle guy comes over and kicks sand in
his face it was like a cartoon and then
you sent 1.99 to Joe Eda and he sent you
back training tips and a trophy that you
were a weightlifter
and you have to do the push-ups and then
you came back a week later and beat the
guy up protected your chick when you had
muscles what a marketing
oh Jesus Christ this is hilarious like I
had little trophies from Joe either oh
that's when you had to order whoopee
cushions right x-ray glasses so they'd
show you X-ray glasses that be a girl in
the bikini and you with x-ray glasses on
like this with your mouth open those
x-ray glasses didn't [__] work you
got beat Jack right then they had
Spanish fly
and I remember that the first time me
and my buddies boyfriend Spanish who
we're gonna give it to and we gave it to
one of my friends grandmother we all
went over there and watched [__]
Donnie and Marie and we just stared at
the grandmother for like two hours to
see if she would scratch her [__]
anything give us a sign that your own
grandma
grandma didn't do [__] so we never
because if she was your eyes were ready
[Laughter]
I'll never forget the kid giving up his
mother he's like [__] let's use it on
my mother
I don't want to say his name because
people I hate him but I still remember
going to his house watching the Donny
and Marie for family hour grandma
is she scratching the [__] yet like is
she fingering herself like we're always
like she's just gonna do that in the
living room yeah he's such a [__]
idiot when you're a kid yeah Spanish
Flies that make a woman go crazy and
that was the ad like the ad was a girl
at a bar and then a girl passed out like
Cosby's and you're [__] that was the
lead that was the ad in the late 60s 70s
you meeting a girl at a bar like with a
martini glass and the next minute you're
both in bed like giggling like making
love that was the ad for Spanish fly so
it guaranteed women will get loose yeah
but then you're not supposed to give it
to the grandma but that was our kid
before we gave it to girls he was a
tester before we gave it to girls in the
seventh grade seventh grade 28th grade
we wanted to test it like we got in the
mail on a Friday and we couldn't wait
we couldn't [__] wait the test on
somebody so this kid volunteered his
grandmother
she said it'll be over there my mom is
going to be out playing cards if she
dies who gives a [__] and we get like we
I never forget he gave Grandma like two
capsules and we put him in like one or
two years yeah Grandma he wants some
warm milk bless your heart we're sitting
there all night [__] howling waiting
for Grandma to start finger banging
herself we left that depressed as [__]
up he lost our investment we were a
bunch of perverted kids and there was a
time he bought a pornos
you can order pornos and it came with a
[__] projector it came with equipment
Super 8 projector so it was a Super 8
projector and an important and two
homemade pornos
and you had to send the money order so
you had to walk up to the [__]
Chinese store or the post office
getting money order you couldn't go to
your mother and get a check in those
days it wasn't like now that they could
deposit the check you had to wait 22
days for a check to clear in the [__]
60s and 70s it was a nightmare
so we had to get a money order and I
still remember waiting six weeks for the
[__] camera to come and it came in a
box and you plugged it in and it was
very frail and it just had two things
and it was super eight so it had two
reels and you connected this one to this
one you press play
and it worked yeah and it would go down
to like and all of a sudden like a
[__] chick that was beat up would
come up and she would start sucking some
guy's dick that was huge and they were
disgusting pornography
it wasn't nothing like what you see
today the chick didn't know she was
being taped
you know most of the times there were
rapes that were being filmed and these
are being mailed to people there was no
legislation nobody nobody nobody getting
[__] was this like a porn magazine
like that where I have this it would be
like a cheap porn magazine that was a
Puerto Rican porn magazine called pika
pika
naked women with their faces covered
why do I want to see that right like
this guy was tricking chicks like he
would take them home and take their
pictures and and put like black over
their eyes and they would show you their
[__] like they had that magazine I
forgot what magazine we got it from but
I remember it was like five of us that
chipped in
and we all went up to my attic and we
[__] put curtains on the wall like a
sheet and we made sandwiches sandwiches
and we thought we were about to see like
this [__] you know like [__] the
fire faucet yeah [__] it was some
chick with flat titties I'd been shot
you know
some black guy with a big big dick the
kid I mean one of the kids you know and
I in the bed I said I wanted the kids
started crying he was like 12. like we
were like 14 13 and we're watching this
big black dick [__] a white chick
like we never saw that before everybody
went home
like when I turn it off turn it off it's
all over like nobody wanted to have sex
no more that's how bad porn was yeah
you could buy anything of the [__]
mail
anything
right out of a [__] magazine the best
was getting magazines and send them to
people's houses
you mean for like just like the CD or
the cassette
you go to the magazine People magazine
that'd be a thing yeah fill it out send
it in we'll send you 10 copies they'd
fill out send it to Lisa airtime
here any one time I went to an office
and there was something I'd send them to
leave and I'd wait for him to say one
night I don't know what's going on I
keep getting these magazines into my
house and I would die a laughter
I would do that to people constantly if
I wanted to [__] with you I'd send you
cabs
and then they're expecting the fare and
everything my grandma's death please
ring the doorbell this [__] was fine
for the bone and stinky my friend stink
used to give them a Luke stick for so
now we're double dating during what six
months he gave it to him like over four
years every once in a while in the
winter
Tasia took Glenn to the other room I got
trenches in the other room now she's
playing Catholic girl she's starting to
cry I don't know it hurts don't put it
too close to my [__] I got a half gram
in my pocket I don't need this
aggravation you know what I'm saying but
six in the morning listen get your life
together we'll go throw some holy water
and it's like it never happened I was a
gentleman
oh I got a half a g in my pocket this
will get me home
and I walked home and guys this is I
walked into the door where I was living
the phone rang and it was her
and she goes I thought about it let's do
it
I was like all right and she picked me
up seven in the morning went back to her
house I gave her a stab and there was
blood there was tears there was a lot of
rub in the back
he gotta rub that back I was gonna say
who's back I gotta rub her back zombies
I'm not a virgin I'm gonna go to hell
don't worry about it yeah
that's like this [__] thing yeah yeah
and guess what like a week later I saw
her she's very cold to me
then we had a couple of them like weird
discussions
I was totally in love with him like I
was in love with them for reals I would
have got married at that age like that's
how in love with her I was
But after those two weeks I was like you
know it's something right here this is
something beyond my control and I was a
criminal
I was a criminal I had no future and I
didn't have
I couldn't see there was no future
so I kind of walked away from a little
bit
I went to Colorado I heard she was
dating some other guy eating pills and
partying
party good friend of mine I don't know
how Alvin never even mentioned it to him
that was me and her were long gone and
and then I went back to New York one day
and I went to a Coke dealer's house and
there she was looking beautiful and she
said hello we talked a little bit
and she said let's stay in touch
between you and you and I in my mind of
the Cooper flown already it wasn't that
I wanted a [__] her I really liked it I
grew up I've been around the last you
know 1978 I had been around this girl
but something wasn't right you know and
six months later I called because she
was a travel agent and I asked if she'd
get me and my buddy's stinky plane
tickets to Hawaii and she goes call me
tomorrow I'll give you a quote when I
call the next day she goes I gotta be
honest to you I'd rather you never call
me again really yeah just like that and
I said
okay okay Sera Sera at the age of 21 I
got one of my biggest lessons of love
[__] them send them roses and move the
[__] up [__] greetings from podcast
bill it was a pleasure to be here on the
first anniversary of your would that be
your inaugural in Carson incarceration
yes that's the first one that is a
pleasure to be here on that anniversary
that it was a Monday morning
and that Friday at 4 30 they called so
that's what I want to ask you did you
know you were gone or did you get caught
in something and taken right now no I
knew you were going to court I knew that
I knew I was there was a good chance of
me going
the prison but I didn't know for sure
till that Friday and what for was this
one for this is for the kid this was
kidnap they called and they said uh the
attorney goes like you said now niggles
Department of
whatever turns you down Community
Corrections
they turned you down so you got two
options you're looking at prison
or you're looking at me putting you into
a work release program but if Community
Corrections turns you down you can't
stay in the community
so he goes right now you're looking at a
10 90 10 whatever you do this week and
have a good weekend
to court Monday at nine
right there I sat I got a little crushed
I took the chicken I was cooking up I
like that little grease on the side
where you put your Italian bread in I
ate it and I go [__] it if this is my
last week and I might as well make it a
good one I didn't cry I didn't freak out
I knew this day was coming
when was the question
so right there I go I'm not gonna go to
jail I'm gonna talk this judge out of it
like that's how cocaine and how we
thought of that one
he was selling drugs me and my friends
were taking the drugs off the street why
come from that's a superhero uh okay so
knock it off with the jail time man this
is a conversation amongst men the
cocaine's off the street you know what
I'm saying yeah everybody's alive let's
let's wrap this up you're well why are
we going to pay the tax [__] pays why
are we going to burden the tax Base
Cocaine told you that was the cocaine
and all weekend long you should have
heard me I was like [__] Trump
without the teleprompters I was [__]
practicing and like telling them like
this is what went down year round and it
no big deal that's no big deal
Monday
and he looked Me Up Up and Down
and my attorney's saying you have uh you
like to address the speech you like to
address the court
and I took two steps forward
and as I went to speak my voice
disappeared
I see about like a little [__] mouthy
[__]
I was like around I just want you to
know that and it just broke and broke
and broke like he was he looked like a
little Fidel Castro with a compact head
he had a tiny little head but it was all
bad he looked like a baby gorilla all
you could see were lips and two little
white Italian eyes
he told me to step back
like I had broken apart like I just fell
apart like I'm not ashamed to say it
whatever speech whatever I had been
doing on playgrounds and parks and delis
for 20 years he scared the [__] out of
me like my my bro here I've never seen
this on mushrooms okay and I don't know
if it's the shrooms or the fact that he
hit his head so goddamn hard on this
thing but I don't know what to do and I
look up at her and she's you know she
see like oh my God it's coming from me
next you know that mindset we're like oh
and I just start smacking him as hard as
I can in the [__] face I'm smacking
the [__] out of him Pink Floyd the pigs
are [__] going oh I just lost my
headphones sorry and um they're banging
and banging and banging and he's having
a seizure and then finally he snaps out
of and everybody's like holy [__] I'm
like dude are you already he's like did
I just pass out I'm like yeah yeah I go
how long do you think you were out he's
like I don't know I felt like three
three minutes he's like yeah I was like
you're out for about 15 seconds I was
like dude but you had a [__] seizure
you're bleeding he's like I'm not
bleeding I'm like are you all right he's
like yeah look over her they're out
they're gone we never saw them again we
go back to [__] Pink Floyd and he's
fine the rest of the night when you meet
these weak people
I went through a million concerts with
everything but heroin balls and nobody
ever [__] fainted that's what I'm
saying yeah
if that happened in my name but you'd
have to move the next day like you have
to pick up a move like dog that's a
[__] lead to a concert and I gave him
a couple mushrooms
it [__] take straight up assets
I didn't take acid to Black Sabbath I
was too young
but I took acid to all those you ever
um you ever smoke weed dipped in PCP
sure what a Sherm or no well this is
what I was getting to okay that
all right so um
16. but hey I'm like the age 15 you're
16. yeah I'm going in that transition
and I'm doing micro dollar acid that's
what it was called it wasn't really that
was those little like one hit tab I mean
tiny you would lose it you had you had
to wrap it in aluminum foil to see them
and you had to take it out of the
aluminum foil and it fits on the floor
you were done sometimes it was purple
sometimes it was pink sometimes it was
brown but it was the size of a middle
school that was the most popular acid it
was 50 50 it was basically rat poison
you did it it was strychnine okay you'd
be grinding your teeth looking around
tremendous but you went for [__]
eight to 12 hours that's a long that's a
crazy
yeah you know now you're like oh thank
God that's gone I have anxiety here you
said that I'd give you another bunker do
another bank and wake it up and then you
said the sunset
and you're like oh thank God I could go
home now and you go home and you drink
milk and you go up to your room and you
lay down also the posters start moving
again it was that type of [__] like it
just did not go away and then uh you see
all this is not a sales point this is
what everyone's ever told me you know it
was just great the one I did to the to
the stones
honestly
that was the first time I had that that
drug
and I wrote about this it was like a
three-day recovery
like for three days
electronic shots going through my spine
like and I was just a young kid and I
was like I think I gotta stop this [__]
like I really do like I had only done it
once but then it was just too much fun
it was the drug of the era it was the
drug like how many I want to tell you
you know the Carlin bit where he talks
about acid right it's like
self-regulating at some point it'll say
stop you know just like the word duh no
so but how many hits would you say
you've had so then let's just say that
let's just do it by freshman year Jesus
freshman year was when we really started
cooking with gas with the ass that's
three a week we would we were three a
week and then something new came along
people are saying you gotta snort this
[__] now I had always made a promise to
myself that I would never snort nothing
but they were like it's just THC stems
stems and people boil them
and they shut the thing off and the
white power that sticks on the side they
scrape that off and that's what you
snorting it's harmless
and it was I had like this I had 18
friends but there was always four that
were like kind of smart and they were
the ones like I want to do it I'm like
you sure
so after weeks of trying I said let me
do a line of that THC Crystal the Keef
like that Keith that's on like the
crystals on the weed it was white
and your snore I have never heard this
one this is brand new to me right now
it's not it's fun it's fun
and we would do it first I did it and I
gave it a break I went back to acid but
what kind of high is it like what do you
feel like [__] Gumby and [__] like
you're about like everything is just
[__] flashing at you is it a
different High than an acid trip it is
eventually
I kept doing it and doing it so I got to
the point where my mother would go to
the track on Sundays and I knew she was
going to be on all day and me and this
kid Carlos Perez but buy a 10 package of
it
and we each got a six pack alone bro
all right yeah I remember alone brought
a lion
yeah tonight is kind of special
must say something more but I'll tonight
let it be low on bro sponsor the church
long bro so [__] we would get long
brows and get [__] up and then go on
Journeys
we just walk and talk [__] when I get
older I want to be a doctor I might know
and we'd just be like cars were almost
hit us like me what the [__] the way
that type of [__] like we would be
[__] up and I found out it was
actually angel dust
somebody talking about life
so that's angel dust pizza
and they turn them into a powder and you
[__] snort them
and I didn't want to [__] know
so we used to play either or we used to
play again either we do acid or we do
Tac
THC crystals they're gone so that's what
it was called until one day somebody
said stupid wake up oh you swung the
animal tranquilizers
how long had you been doing it would you
say before you actually found out what
about three and a half months
I remember one time I smoked it with a
pregnant chick
in 1983 they would they would sell it in
Harlem and you could smoke and it was
called the tray it was three dollars it
was a tray and it was basically enough
powder to sprinkle a joint with
and you could smoke it that was that was
it'd be December January February of 84.
no no of 83. maybe December of 82 it was
cold out
and uh I remember getting high with her
maybe 10 30 in the morning
and take a being on the bus at nine
o'clock
Kennedy Boulevard dropping me off on the
corner and crossing the street to the
bar going wow
thank God I finally got it together like
I walked in and I was still a little
Gumby dust
because then it was just called Gumby
dust it was like animal tranquilizing
yeah so I wanted to tear of that [__]
me and my buddies were tearing that
stuff up that's why today like I said
before I don't know what day I'm gonna
go on stage [__] in my hand and take it
out and throw it at the audience because
one of these days one of these cylinders
is going to snap yeah and the real Joey
Diaz is Gonna Come Out The Mensch is
definitely my future
especially if we did these this [__] at
the age of 13 years yeah it's early
that's hard stuff early too early I I
partied so hard my freshman going into
sophomore year like I put in the
hospital at September
because it had a lung infection
and they threw me out on September 28
1979.
and I got out of the hospital at 11
o'clock at eight o'clock that night I
was smoking dope and doing Ashley Jesus
Christ it was like Muhammad Ali fought
somebody
[Laughter]
I still got more corn on my my brother's
ex-wife's
house is on that corner and I know what
the house we sat on the steps like and I
and I kept doing that powder and I kept
snorting that [__] and then one day I
walked into the basement
and my mom had these friends that she
would hold [__] for downstairs
but it was always weed bales of weed
like the coffee beans and bells and I
would take a little off the top and I
would spray it with water to maintain
the weight yeah like the holes in
the 12 ounces of water in the middle so
it would stay heavy so when they put on
the scale I was a [__] genius oh
that's great and I [__] uh but one
time I went down and it wasn't uh
wheat it was coke
a couple of bales of Coke
saw it open up the bells and [__]
take a gram I wouldn't do
I would give it to a buddy of mine that
was a real cool dude and he would say
where'd you get that [__] oh my God I
saw Chinese people you know
you know real cocaine and [__] and every
once in a while I'd scrape a little and
take it and give it to him this went on
for about a month or two then the guy
became a cop so now I owned
yeah you know I knew he was going to do
something with his life
he became a cop boom now I owned him but
that's not the point of the story I held
on to that one one dad took it and I
would surprise him
like in 1979 when somebody would
surprise you with cocaine
you pretty much sucked this day
in 1979 walking into a room with cocaine
those two chicks with my suck your dick
they knew forget Harvey Weinstein you
you'd make Harvey Weinstein look like a
[__] gay guy
That's How Strong the power of cocaine
was
guys like me could get laid women were
doing disgusting things it was a
different level of disgust because it
meant you had power it was like this
social
if you came out of the bathroom and you
went the whole bar would look at you and
come over and rub your shoulders how is
it it's
semi-intense you know
that's what was going on yeah you're 54.
this cocaine Freedom makes me you know
so that [__] sold it made white people
go crazy but at the same time I hadn't
done it
I held down to that little package then
the night before some cats call me up
and they're like we're playing hooky
tomorrow
so I said [__] let me bring the
packets and see if we'll have but these
guys are too straight there was like
eight of us but one of the other dudes
was a genius and him and I used to do
[__] that angel does [__] at school
from time to time
and one day I gave my line he thought it
was coke I gave him a line of that [__]
and he had a wrestling match
and he was on the bottom and he made a
movie he bit the guy he got disqualified
and people were like why would you bite
the guy [__] Coco gave me [__] THC
crystals
[__] that's what we all called it to uh
to avoid the pain of what it really
right yeah you know my brother
um he and a buddy I actually told this
whole story on my album but he in a an
uh a cousin brought some [__] home one
time and they called it Sherm it was a
and and they would call Paul Chuck Paul
that's what they call PCP Paul Chuck
Paul and they would um they would it was
popular for a little while to dip this
[__] in PCP these joints and I I thought
it was a myth at first I was like yeah
it doesn't happen because you hear [__]
on like Oprah people doing it dipping
their cigarettes and cooking their
babies and [__] like insane stuff that
these suffocating kids and freezers like
and um they decided to smoke it in front
of me and you know I tell that story but
the thing was I thought it was a one and
done thing for them you know what I mean
like I knew they had done it but
it's like the summer of 94. I'm fresh
off the Pink Floyd concert I go back to
Maryland for the summer before for
between College
and I'm seeing this girl at the time and
we're going to Lollapalooza now
originally Nirvana was gonna headline
I'm almost positive it's 94 and then
Cobain died
um so he brought the Smashing Pumpkins
in to fill that space and it was a great
it was like Tribe Called Quest I think
the Beastie Boys were there [__]
P-Funk was there uh the Smashing
Pumpkins like it was it was a good one
um and
um
they're smoking a joint
and I don't think anything of it I just
think it's a joint and the girl I'm
seeing at the time goes over to take a
hit you know she smokes weed
and she comes back she's like that
tasted really weird and I was like you
[__] and I went over to my
brother I'm like is that [__] wheat
or is that that [__] you were smoking me
no it's the [__] I go what are you
[__] you can't just let some you got
to tell somebody that well we thought
she knew I'm like why would anyone
assume that you're smoking PCP laced
weed over here why would anyone why
would that be your immediate it probably
should be the way you treat life but why
would anyone assume that anyway they
make the best top shelf margarita in the
country at the time for 450. Red Robin
my credit card
Margarita Margarita Red Robin Red Bro I
would go to Red Robin every night do two
margaritas two two top shelves do two
bumps and [__] some man whatever you
need me to do I'll do you know what I'm
saying I would have a little car sales
and he'd drive me home he kept asking me
you don't have no more coke no I did it
all I had to grab my pocket I'd go home
and [__] bang out blow and then I got
promoted now
I'm thinking about the salesmanship the
guy told me what they're making over
there
and there was a lot more than what I was
making
I'm like should I go over and sell
[__] cars
I don't know nothing about cars
and these are the same ones the actors
the Subarus the Mitsubishi okay
so these guys back then they had to what
the brat they were the one with the
seats in the back remember those
suicides
back then
so I'm gonna be this real decisive mode
but what happened was
there was a crew of detailers and this
just happens to me in all places
what happened was I started out working
I started how to figure out this system
the system was to do two new cars a day
and three used cars that's where your
money's at
the two new cars with easy money you
just rip the paper off you got to put a
certain chemical on them to take the
cosmoline off you put the rims on you
Armor All the inside you put the mats
down you wash the car and you drive
that's it it's no big deal nobody's ever
sat in the car you just gotta put the
hubcaps on put the [__] mats in you
know a couple things you gotta adjust
set the stations whatever the [__] they
want then you take it to the thing I can
do two of those in an hour
so I would make two [__] runs and
they never heard of that
I'm like why go make runs and pick them
up let's get two done
and I did two canoe cars by the 11 and
then I jump on three used cars I was
making some good [__] money but they
started [__] with me
you know they wouldn't give me a bay
they would go oh if you could park two
cars out there we could put two cars in
here
so it's like really four against three
and the supervisor like them
so I'm like this supervisor really wants
to [__] with me and then like a week
after that one day he goes I'm gonna
[__] write you up
for insubordination something crazy
because I told them I'll do the car
outside no big deal you can't do it
outside I go relax watch your [__]
tone
and then but the manager was from New
York and the manager knew I was a little
[__] up and the owner was a great
white dude you know those white dudes
that drink whiskey and they don't watch
porn but they appreciate a good sense of
humor you could tell that the dude was
uptight and [__] yeah he was just a
great white dude but he liked me because
I [__] made money and I hustled my
[__] you know I was getting in there
with him it's six in the morning you
weren't supposed to be that too late if
I started cocktail five what's the
difference sit here and look out the
window by myself I might as well go pick
up a piece of [__] Thirty forty
dollars at the time that was my
mentality so they started picking on me
they started [__] with me like they
really you're gonna [__] with me and at
that time I had the whole body shop why
and I knew where to get weed I knew
where to get Coke
I knew who was selling this who was
selling that there was a creepy dude who
installed stereos there
creepy as [__]
in what way every day man I went to the
strip club last night I met this girl
Melinda her working name was Gunner
you know he's really creepy that's a
fake real name like just a creepy strip
club guy
he knew all the strip clubs when people
would talk about strip clubs he'd come
out and give you cards for VIP of this
one he was friends with the band The
Rental the Banderas bike gang
I got reefer from him I got Coke from
him
he sold a bunch of [__] but he had
everything a guy
that was trying to prove something had
tinted windows a loud stereo tattoos
leather jacket a motorcycle a pit bull
anything that a guy needs to get
attention yeah he was just
but he was like a half a [__] but I
kind of liked them his drugs were good
he always told me about dirty [__] how
he would finger these strippers and he
would [__] them and all this [__] so
speaking of drugs can we smoke during
this
you can light your ass off
so
one day this dude Dirk
gets in my face
about some [__] I've told this story
before but I don't think I told it to
you Ryan sickler I want to hear it I'm
[__] not trying I'm 24. no [__] fresh
out of [__] Jersey
I just slept in benches I just went
through that whole [__] homeless
thing
you know now I'm living in Boulder but
I'm keeping a lid on it
I got a girlfriend I have to go to a
family's house every Sunday to eat
they're very nice people
they're from Buffalo
they're from Buffalo New York they're
very nice people I appreciate them
so I gotta act like a [__] man and
these people getting in my faces
so there was particularly two white
dudes both from Minneapolis Minnesota
that would [__] with me and they had a
and they would beat me because they had
the
the [__] the supervisor the
supervisor in that corner
so one day I see the supervisor walking
in
and I don't know what he took his jacket
off and he hung it up
and I don't know what made me do this
but this is the mind that Joey Diaz you
know the the dude thought he got over on
me yeah but I'm gonna show him I'm gonna
get over on him I just didn't know how
and all of a sudden the good Lord does
something he does every [__] day he
kills a mouse
I turn around and there's a dead mouse
four foot from me maybe three inches
long
I see that everybody's washing cars I go
what can I do with this mouse I got a
paper towel I pick it up by the town I
put it in the guy's pocket
the supervisor's pocket I put in his
pocket I get high I keep working on cars
I forget about the whole thing
the next morning I'm in there is six
o'clock buzzing out a car and you hear a
car coming like
and he gets on the car and he goes what
the [__] shut it down shut it down I
just got into a major car accident he
goes I reached him in my pocket for
cigarettes and somebody put a mouse in
there
by the end of the day I'm gonna find out
who it is I have an idea who it is and
I'm [__] you know me dog I'm like
I'll help you find the phone yeah
but that [__] knew it was me or
some other guy his car was all crashed
up [__] them
[__]
so right there I knew it was time for me
to go
so by April 15th I we're in April now
everybody April 1980s I tell the [__]
I tell the [__] uh
the [__] car the dealership the I
caught him a deal
I tell the detail guys that
I'm gonna go sell cars for one day and
try it
and after one day I know if I like it or
not
and they said okay
when do you want to do this like a
Monday
so I put together what I had as a suit
at that time
and I went there Monday they told me to
be that eight to learn about some cars
and they gave me to this guy named Jimmy
wheeler God Rest his soul to his son I
still talked to his son it's amazing
that you remember these Cody wheeler I
remember this guy's name because
he was the first guy that made me feel
like family without being at home
he was one of those guys that he was
willing to take a a bullet for you and
again God put this guy in my life
and on the first day he just dug me we
were Big Time Bruce Lee fans that's why
I brought you to sure thank you for that
shirt
and he had the tower jikun doe signed by
Bruce Lee nobody had that at the time
and he was from Detroit he just
impressed the [__] out of me and he gave
me a shirt once Detroit the murder
capital of the United States of America
it was my favorite shirt I wore it all
summer long people said to me why do you
wear that shirt it's disgusting I
[__] love Detroit I want to go to
[__] Detroit like I I'm ready for
Detroit [__] these [__] like that's
how crazy I was at the time
and that first day with Jim wheeler I
ended up selling three cars
making a thousand bucks on paper and
like 200 and spiffs cash
at seven o'clock I called The Body Shop
and told him to suck my dick I'm never
washing the car again
I went to my mother-in-law God bless us
all my ex-mother-in-law oh I love daily
at the time and she lent me her uh made
dnf card
and she let me charge 500 I bought three
suits
shirts pants
and I was all in guys you were selling
cars in Denver well not Denver and the
first month I ended up selling 14 cars
damn I was just that's every other day
damn near I was a Salesman of the month
I think I came in second did you get a
special spot and all that [__] yeah like
I got a demo for free you got to sell 12
cards to get your car for free or you
had to pay 300 a month so that was the
magic number 12 you get your demo and
then dad weird bonuses like once you
sell 10 cars your bonus goes from 20 to
30 percent 11 cars 35 12 cars 40 percent
uh 15 cars 40 plus a 500 cash bonus they
worked it plus every new Subaru you
called every new Subaru you sold you
ripped the thing
and you looked at it and they'd really
give you money or you spun the wheel you
called Subaru and they tell you you won
350 and you'll get your check in the
mail
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]